your heart pumps blood to your brain
through blood vessels in your neck these
blood vessels called arteries branch
into even smaller arteries that bring
blood to your brain cells some of these
small arteries join each other to form a
loop known as the Circle of Willis
the walls of the arteries contain
special muscle
and elastic layers that help them adapt
to the blood pulsing through them
sometimes diseases injuries or birth
defects can cause a weak spot in the
wall of the arteries in the Circle of
Willis
these weak spots usually form where
arteries branch over time the pressure
of blood flowing through the artery
stresses the weak spot further
constant blood pressure can cause the
weak spot to balloon out and form a
bulge called a cerebral aneurysm this
cerebral aneurysm is the most common
type called a circular or berry aneurysm
over time the aneurysm may grow and push
on nearby brain tissue or nerves blood
may also leak from the aneurysm
if its wall gets too thin the aneurism
can burst or rupture and spill
high-pressure blood into the space
around your brain
the blood presses on your brain tissue
and can cause injury to your brain cells
chemicals in the escaped blood can
irritate other brain arteries and cause
them to narrow
as a result your brain can swell leading
to serious brain injury
common symptoms of a ruptured cerebral
aneurysm include sudden severe headache
sometimes called a thunderclap headache
problems with your vision such as
blurred or double vision nausea and
vomiting
a stiff or painful neck
or confusion
an unruptured cerebral aneurysm may not
cause symptoms but large unruptured
aneurysm z' may cause headache and pain
near or behind one eye
double or blurred vision
a drooping eyelid
and numbness or weakness on one side of
your face
a ruptured cerebral aneurysm is a
medical emergency if you are having
symptoms seek immediate medical
attention
if you have a ruptured cerebral aneurysm
your doctor may recommend Surgical
clipping or endovascular coiling
in surgical clipping your surgeon will
make an opening in your skull near your
aneurysm and place a small metal clip
onto the stem that connects the aneurysm
to your artery the clip blocks blood
flow into your aneurysm
in endovascular coiling your doctor will
put a plastic tube called a catheter
into a large artery in your groin
using a live x-ray view your doctor will
advance the catheter through your
arteries
until it reaches the aneurysm through
the catheter your doctor will insert one
or more flexible wires into your
aneurysm the wires will coil up and
cause a blood clot to form inside your
aneurysm which will block off the
aneurysm from the rest of your artery
in a similar manner if you have an
unruptured cerebral aneurysm your doctor
may recommend surgical clipping or
endovascular coiling in addition if your
aneurysm is small and not causing pain
or other symptoms
your doctor may observe your aneurysm
for a period of time before performing
either of these procedures